David when you commit to a project what
are some of the first things you do to
get into character and to kind of get
yourself ready for that role you know it
always starts with the script and the
director of course and just being able
to kind of you know go through the
script intensely and find out you know
what you connect with and and then um
and then depending on that is how you
start your research and you don't get in
shape and though I'm sure the research
for Jack was probably entertaining I
have to ask you this how many days of
sex scenes were there on site let's just
go right for it I know it was pretty
intense I mean the craziest scene was
its high-speed so we just have to sit
there for 20-30 minutes and do a bunch
of different positions and the cameras
just rolling and you kind of get lost in
the fact that uh it's just you and her
the crew walked away yeah we set cameras
up shooting one frame per second and I
said David and I just have some fun have
fun together and that we had been they
had been we'd been doing the movie for
three weeks now they were very
comfortable everybody went away far away
so it was just the two of them with
cameras and lights and it was shot you
know time lapse essentially and I think
we left you alone for about an hour
maybe an hour and a half it was really
well it was like the longest universe
David did do all the artwork in the
movie all that art is his own art he
painted he did the the book he did all
the artwork so he did that was a lot of
prep there as well yeah for sure the art
was a big part of it and originally one
of the earlier just that was a writer he
was a writer you know because there was
so much of that's right in my original
draft he was writer and we changed him
to an artist because David is a really
great artist just going back to the sex
scenes again and having a freedom sorry
that's
explore sexuality I mean it's solved
what it's all about essentially sure in
marriage and secrets like that it's a
lot if you communication yeah and also
obsession and like what turns you on you
know the thing about his character is he
pushes this whole thing forward he's
kind of turned on by his wife sleeping
with someone else it gets him it makes
him jealous but it also really gets him
excited and it reconnects their their
marriage in some ways so it's kind of
it's a about one of the things it's
about is how complicated human beings
are sexually so how did he pitch the
script to you oh he actually sent the
script to me he was working with Joanna
ray casting director that I love and and
she's wonderful
and he said doing this film I'm
interested in you for it and I read the
script and you know that's all it took
it's just such a I know what an
incredible director jeffrey is so just
it's sort of envisioning what he's gonna
do with this whole world and how
different it look and and the it's still
I can't even wrap my head around it it's
such a interesting art piece it's it's
definitely like an art piece rather than
just a film very much so we always hear
that films that are in the 1 to 10
million range are the hardest to not
only get me but also make your money
back on how are you able to do that with
the key I don't know I know you haven't
shown it yet so in terms of investors
how did you pitch this time no I
my company financed the movie we shot it
at my house with all my own equipment
here where we are I own all the
equipment the crew worked for and the
cast worked for very little I you know
so I am in a place where I just wanted
to make the movie and I'm hoping I can
make you know the money back on the
movie we'll see well you're doing
something very interesting and you are
hosting a Film Festival November 21st
through the 28th and I believe both
films that
he and me will play before each
submission right why do it that way well
we just wanted to kind of the idea is
that what I'm trying to do with the
studio is really experiment and not just
experiment with content but experiment
with the entire process of filmmaking
the kind you know how you do the film's
how you post the films how you
distribute the film's we also wanted to
sort of and how you socialize the films
how you start a Film Society and make
things happen that way so the idea was
to get some filmmakers who wanted to
show their films and let them we're
calling it it's like guest filmmakers
and for the first week there's six or
seven guest filmmakers that are coming
in and showing their films one time
including Susan trailer who I did me
with she has a great film which has
never been seen called welcome to
California which is a fantastic
experimental film that she made and I
wanted to open to give other people a
chance to be part of this whole thing so
that was the sort of it's it's kind of a
an idea sort of a social idea you know
and the and also we're I'm trying to
raise money to buy a theater in Los
Angeles which will show exclusively
digital independent films it'll be like
a Film Festival 365 days a year I'm
trying to buy the actual the Fine Arts
Theatre on Wilshire Boulevard near La
Cienega and it would be kind of like
this ongoing thing we would only show
independent films that didn't get
distribution elsewhere but if you would
come there and there'd be little cafe
and there there would be people talking
about films and blah blah blah and all
this stuff like an ongoing Film Festival
all the time but nonprofit and that's
really really key for me nonprofit the
film festivals have become the big ones
for profit almost they seem like they're
corporate entities and so they're trying
to put butts in seats and they need big
stars and blah blah blah it would be the
opposite of that
and so we're trying to experiment and
see if this works and see what happens
in order to as I'm raising money to do
this project this is nonprofit project
David I enjoyed your role as Jack and I
found him edgy and very human but are
you afraid of how other directors may
feel oh well he can only do sort of this
dark almost voyeur type of character and
not a Disney role I mean do you ever
feel afraid that you're going to get
sort of pigeon-holed in one way or
another I don't really know I don't
really worry about that because you know
I mean someone could pigeonhole me as
like a goofy comedian you know if they
wanted to for certain roles that I've
done so doing it feeling like this
actually gives me an opportunity to show
aside that a lot of people don't know
the voice thank you you know sexual
charged side you know that uh I actually
don't get the opportunity to play
characters like that very often so no
soccer dad roles you what you you enjoy
sort of delving into did Beethoven
didn't you diss the kids cartoon so you
know I've been in the business for 27
years professionally and business for 25
years kid I just like to you know mix it
up and do different things and you know
there are many films there's no film
like the key and what he's done here is
really unique and interesting and having
an opportunity to act in in projects
that are so different and so unique and
so artistic based is just a luxury just
to be able to be a part of it this is
the kind of collaborator you want
someone who's an artist David is a
really he is a an artist himself but
he's in many different ways
in many different areas including acting
but also Fine Arts magic all sorts of
things but he's also so so he was
incredibly supportive of this whole
thing and really like inspire
me too to push this really far